so I'm gonna put on some death metal
music here
just a generalist of boops realism is
not exactly what we're going for
oh wow
this did not go as I wanted it too
no no no no no no no no this game
correctly I just
wait get off the skateboard
[Laughter]
died again
my legs I'm about to meet my oncoming
Doom
do y'all they ain't got nothing on this
dog
hit it hit it
and death
what's the matter Bobby don't feel so
good you don't look so good either but
that's just cause you're ugly
oopsies
your character model is Shifty eyes Mark
really maybe it's because of this or
this
oh
my God
foreign
I was wondering if Wade would go back to
his douchey fish ways hi
you're not dead where'd you go oh no I
lost
all right
all right because the last time with a
fluke are gonna try this again all right
kid he's three times
I'm gonna lose zombie
ah zombie zombie no ah
why oh that's not good
you look good sailor smack again
this is absolutely why would my
how are you doing I got a new friend
here where are you going where where's
he going ah I can't see him
God
ah he's crawling in my bro what was that
eyes crawling in my brain super speed
yeah that is like way too many jets or
not enough
[Laughter]
okay
[Applause]
it's burrowing out of my brain oh I'm
coming oh come on you're so evil come
over here I think he's jumping off I can
jump off dude you coming over there you
over you going
oh
zombie you're in so much trouble
hello hi I'm gonna call you Billy and
I'm gonna call you Smitty werbin
jagerman Jensen oh oh no no no my
bed ah today
oh it's a goddamn nightmare
hi get away from me
hi
[Laughter]
oh my God
oh
my God thanks for watching all of the
videos in this compilation are available
in the description so check them out and
if you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis Please
Subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye-bye